washington where cbs news has confirmed
that president biden has chosen a
nominee for the supreme court it will be
a black woman as he has promised what we
don't know at this hour is who it will
be a recent cbs news poll asked how
important diversity is on the court and
the answer broke down along racial lines
most black americans say it's very or at
least somewhat important that is less
the case for white americans jan
crawford is outside the supreme court
for us good morning so we have a choice
we just don't know who
that's right tony president biden has
interviewed his top three contenders and
they are d.c based federal appeals court
judge katanji brown jackson california
supreme court justice leandra kruger and
south carolina federal court judge
michelle childs now jackson has long
been considered the front runner she was
on former president obama's shortlist
back in 2016 for the supreme court she's
a harvard harvard law school honors
graduate she was a law clerk actually
for justice stephen breyer the man that
she may now replace but the other two
contenders also highly regarded leonda
krueger the one on the california
supreme court and she is just considered
this dazzling intellect she's also a
former supreme court clerk and argued 12
cases before the justices while she was
working in the obama administration
judge childs on the other hand she's a
favorite of south carolina congressman
jim clyburn and she stands out as the
only non-ivy leaguer of the three now
president biden could make his uh
announcement as soon as today and
certainly uh by monday and the day
before the state of the union adriana
all right well the wait continues dan
thanks so much